THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
HEARING TODAY IN ROOM 22,200 OF
THE Þ STREET BUILDING. I ASK
THAT ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE COME TO THE HEARING SO
THAT WE CAN BEGIN. WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF HEARINGS GOING ON, SO
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET EVERYBODY
HERE. BUT IT LOOKS LIKE WE CAN
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND I
APPRECIATE SENATOR CIERTO, BEING
HERE WITH ME. WE HAVE 28
MEASURES ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
THERE WILL BE A SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS TO START THINGS OFF
WITH SEVEN MEASURES THAT ARE
PART OF A PACKAGE OF BILLS TO
ADDRESS ISSUES AROUND RETAIL
THEFT. THERE IS TIME
SENSITIVITY, SO WE WILL BE
ENTERTAINING Dð PASS MOTIONS ON
THESE MEASURES. ONCE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. ONCE WE MOVE ON TO THE
REGULAR AGENDA, WE HAVE TWO
OTHER MEASURES THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR Dð PASS MOTION, AND THE
REMAINING ITEMS ARE SUSPENSE
CANDIDATES. ALL MEMBERS WITH
SUSPENSE ITEMS BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE THIS MORNING HAVE
WAIVED PRESENTATION. WE WILL BE
TAKING TESTIMONY FROM THE FROM
THE PUBLIC ON EACH AND EVERY
ITEM, EVEN IF THE AUTHOR HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. BEFORE WE
BEGIN, I WANT TO REMIND ANY
WITNESSES TO LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILL. SO PLEASE REFRAIN
FROM LENGTHY POLICY DISCUSSIONS
AND REPEATING PRIOR TESTIMONY IN
YOUR COMMENTS. AS I SAID, WE DO
NOT HAVE A QUORUM, SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE RIGHT INTO OUR
BUSINESS, AS A SUBCOMMITTEE
UNTIL WE GET ENOUGH MEASURES,
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 1779 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. PLEASE
COME FORWARD. AND WELCOME. THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE TO START THE
HEARING. THANK YOU, VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. GOOD MORNING. I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 1779,
WHICH RETURNS AUTHORITIES TO
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS TO JOIN
CHARGES FOR MULTIPLE COUNTIES
INTO ONE TRIAL WHEN PROSECUTING
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT RINGS
ACROSS MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS.
THIS BILL IS PART OF THE
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AGAINST
RETAIL CRIME PACKAGE OF BILLS.
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT CONTINUES
TO PLAGUE OUR COMMUNITIES. ITS
RESULTING FINANCIAL IMPACT
BURDENS NOT ONLY RETAILERS BUT
ALSO FAMILIES TRYING TO PURCHASE
HOUSEHOLD GOODS, I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE PROVISIONS
THAT WERE ADDED TO THE BILL IN
THE ASSEMBLY, REQUIRING THE
AGREEMENT OF ALL DA'S INVOLVED,
AS WELL AS A JOINDER HEARING TO
PREVENT ANY UNFAIR AND
PREJUDICIAL CONSOLIDATION FROM
TAKING PLACE, THANK YOU. AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT WHEN THE TIME IS
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE HERE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL? IF SO, PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MIC. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING, MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. CORY SALZILLO
, ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL, AS IN
PRINT, WE WOULD REMOVE OUR
SUPPORT. UNFORTUNATELY IF WE'RE
AMENDED AS PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS. BUT AS THE BILL SITS,
WE ARE SUPPORT AS LONG AS IT'S
NOT AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NICOLE WATERMAN,
ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR DAN FELIZARDO, ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? PLEASE
INVITE YOU TO COME FORWARD.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE, I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT,
YOU HAVE TAKEN THE AMENDS. I
THOUGHT I HEARD YOU SAY THAT IN
YOUR OPENING, I DID NOT SAY
THAT. I BUT THE AMENDS WERE WE
WILL HAVE TO TAKE THE AMENDS.
YES. ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD, IS
THERE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS,
SENATOR? CIERTO I HAVE A
QUESTION. ARE THE AMENDS IN
THERE OR NOT? RIGHT NOW, I THINK
THEY'RE BEING PUT IN IN THIS
COMMITTEE. OKAY, SO THE
AMENDMENTS AREN'T. WE'RE HEARING
IT. THEY WEREN'T THEY WERE NOT
IN THE PUB. THEY WERE NOT PUT IN
IN THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.
OKAY. SO IT'S GOING TO BE A DO
PASS AS AMENDED. CORRECT. OKAY.
SO THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE HAS A
$150,000 PER YEAR, PRICE TAG.
AND OUR LIMIT WHERE WE PUT
THINGS INTO SUSPENSE IS 100. I
MEAN, IS 50. SO WHY IS THIS NOT
GOING TO SUSPENSE WITH THE OTHER
BILLS THAT COST MORE THAN
$50,000? THAT WOULD BE A
QUESTION FOR THE CHAIR OR STAFF.
YES. AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS
BECAUSE THIS IS PART OF A
PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT, DEAL WITH
RETAIL THEFT THAT HAVE BEEN
PRIORITIZED AND THAT INCLUDES
SENATE BILLS AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
BILLS. THIS IS ONE OF THE BILLS.
SO AS STATED IN THE LAST
COMMITTEE, BECAUSE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING PUT
IN, ESPECIALLY THE INOPERABILITY
AMENDMENT, WE WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL, WE'LL BE
ABSTAINING FROM IT UNTIL THEY
HAVE THE LANGUAGE IN PRINT, AND
WE'RE ABLE TO, WEIGH OUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
INOPERABILITY NONSENSE. THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
YOU MAY CONCLUDE, JUST AGAIN,
ASK FOR YOUR. AYE VOTE WHEN THE
TIME COMES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
THIS MORNING. ALL RIGHT. THAT IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. AGAIN, WE
WILL WAIT UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM
, TO, TO MAKE A MOTION ON THIS.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO, FILE
ITEM NUMBER. OKAY ACTUALLY,
WE'RE GOING TO SKIP THAT ONE
BECAUSE HE'S NOT HERE YET. WE'LL
MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE, AB 1802 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER. WELCOME,
SIR. THANK YOU. AND AGAIN, THERE
THERE IS AN AMENDS AS WELL. YES.
AND I WILL BE TAKING. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
MEMBERS. I PRESENT AB 1802,
WHICH WILL ELIMINATE THE SUNSETS
ON THE CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT AND THE OPERATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
PROPERTY CRIMES TASK FORCE. THIS
BILL IS PART OF AN ASSEMBLY
PACKAGE OF BILLS TO ADDRESS
RETAIL THEFT IN CALIFORNIA. IN
2017, I AUTHORED ASSEMBLY BILL
1065, WHICH IS THE OG OF ALL THE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT BILLS
WHICH CREATED A CRIME OF
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT AND
ESTABLISHED THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL PROPERTY CRIMES
TASK FORCE. TO DATE, THE TASK
FORCE HAS RECOVERED OVER $30
MILLION IN STOLEN GOODS. AB 1802
ELIMINATES THE SUNSET FROM MY
ORIGINAL BILL AND MAKES THE
CRIME OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
AND A CHP TASK FORCE PERMANENT.
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN CALIFORNIA. THE
AMENDMENTS ENSURE THAT THIS BILL
WILL TAKE PLACE IMMEDIATELY AND
ALLOW AMPLE LEGISLATIVE
FLEXIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE TAKEN NECESSARY STEPS TO
PREVENT RETAIL THEFT WHILE NOT
REVERTING TO OVERLY PUNITIVE
METHODS PROVEN NOT TO WORK. THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY TO ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO UTILIZE THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INVESTED INTO RETAIL THEFT
PREVENTION OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS. AB 1802 WILL ENSURE THAT
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS THE
NECESSARY MEANS TO ARREST AND
PROSECUTE THE ORGANIZED CRIME
RINGS THAT CONTINUE TO DISRUPT
LIFE IN THE GOLDEN STATE. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS DAN FELIZARDO ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL'S SPONSOR, LOS
ANGELES DISTRICT ATTORNEY GEORGE
GASCON. MADAM CHAIR, MEMBER
STANFIELD, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE, AS THE AUTHOR
STATED, THIS BILL WILL ELIMINATE
THE SUNSET, THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL, ARE REALLY
MINOR. THE ANALYSIS NOTED COURT
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL.
HOWEVER, I JUST WANT TO NOTE
THAT EVEN IF WE WERE NOT
PROSECUTING THESE INDIVIDUALS
UNDER THIS STATUTE, WE WOULD BE
PROSECUTING THEM UNDER OTHER
THEFT STATUTES. SO THE COURT
COSTS ARE GOING TO EXIST
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR NOT,
1802, IS ON THE BOOKS, SO WE,
RESPECT FULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE,
VOTE, BECAUSE WE BELIEVE FOR
THIS COMMITTEE, THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL ARE
MINOR, INCARCERATION COSTS ARE
LOCAL. THEY WON'T BE AT CDCR. SO
WE, LIKE, SAY, ASK FOR YOUR
EYES. VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE. ANYONE
ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION? IN SEEING
NO ONE COME FORWARD. BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR CONCERNS?
I'LL MAKE MY COMMENT. SO THIS
BILL HAS THE SAME PROBLEM AS THE
LAST ONE. IT'S $3.1 MILLION.
DESPITE THE, COMMENTS BY THE
WITNESS, THE INCREASE IN COURT
COSTS WILL BE BECAUSE THEY'RE
GOING TO ACTUALLY ARREST PEOPLE
AND THEY'RE GOING TO ACTUALLY
TRY PEOPLE. AND SO THERE WILL BE
INCREASED COURT COSTS OVER WHAT
WE'RE DOING TODAY, BECAUSE THOSE
PEOPLE CAN BE ALREADY THE ONES
THAT ARE BEING ARRESTED TODAY
SHOULD ALREADY BE BEING
ARRESTED. SO THERE'S THAT THE
COSTS WE'RE ALREADY ABSORBING
THOSE. WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IS AN ADDITIONAL LOAD WHICH WE
SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE OF THIS. BUT
IT'S $3.1 MILLION. SO THAT'S 20
TIMES AS MUCH AS THE LAST BILL.
AND SO AGAIN, THIS ONE SHOULD BE
SENT TO SUSPENSE WITH THE REST
OF THEM. AND THAT'S ONE OF MY
OBJECTIONS. ALSO, WITH THE
INTEROPERABILITY. I OBJECT TO
THAT ALSO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL. SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO CONCLUDE THIS IS YOUR TIME, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WHEN
WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL WE'LL
TAKE THIS MATTER UP. THANK YOU
ALSO FOR BEING HERE. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. WE DON'T HAVE IS
THIS ONE RIGHT HERE IN THE
AUDIENCE, MR. Ó. THAT'S A
ZIPPER ASSEMBLY. MEMBERS OF BR
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX, WHICH IS
AB 2943. THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE ON TIME AS WELL. I'M KIND
OF GOING THROUGH THE MEMBERS
THAT HAVEN'T SHOWN UP YET. AND
THEY'RE WELL OVER THE ON TIME
CAUCUS ASSEMBLY. YOU KNOW WHAT I
DO APPRECIATE IT. THAT'S WHY I'M
MAKING A POINT OF SAYING TO
EVERYONE, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE ON TIME, BECAUSE IT
IS IMPORTANT TO OUR, OPERATION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, I'M PROUD TO SERVE AS
A JOINT AUTHOR, ALONG WITH
SPEAKER RIVAS ON THIS BILL, AB
2943, THE CALIFORNIA RETAIL
THEFT REDUCTION ACT. THIS BILL
IS A PRIMARY COMPONENT OF A
BROADER, COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY
AND PACKAGE OF BILLS THAT
ADVANCES BALANCED, EFFECTIVE,
AND MEANINGFUL SOLUTIONS TO
RETAIL CRIME AND ENDEAVORS TO
PRESERVE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORMS THAT HAVE BEEN EFFECTIVE
AT KEEPING OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE.
WE'VE ENDEAVORED TO ACHIEVE
CONSENSUS WHEREVER POSSIBLE, AND
THE PROPOSALS IN THIS BILL ARE
AN OUTGROWTH OF THE WORK OF THE
ASSEMBLY SELECT COMMITTEE,
SELECT COMMITTEE ON RETAIL
THEFT, WHICH HAS HELD TWO
COMPREHENSIVE HEARINGS FEATURING
A RANGE OF EXPERT PERSPECTIVES
AND THE PRODUCT OF EXTENSIVE
ENGAGEMENT AMONG THE SPEAKERS.
OFFICE AND SENATE LEADERSHIP,
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, AND WITH
POLICY EXPERTS AND KEY
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
RETAILERS, WORKERS, CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM ADVOCATES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THE BILL PLACES
GREAT EMPHASIS ON STOPPING
ORGANIZED CRIME RINGS THAT ARE
HARMING OUR COMMUNITIES. IT DOES
THIS BY CREATING A NEW CRIME
TARGETING SERIAL THIEVES WITH A
PENALTY OF UP TO THREE YEARS
BEHIND BARS FOR POSSESSION OF
STOLEN PROPERTY, WITH THE INTENT
TO RESELL. IT ALSO SPECIFIES
THAT EVIDENCE OF INTENT CAN
INCLUDE REPEATED CONDUCT OR
POSSESSION OF A QUANTITY OF
GOODS, AND CONSISTENT WITH
PERSONAL USE, IT DOES NOT
REQUIRE PROOF THAT A DEFENDANT
ACTED WITH ANOTHER PERSON AND
APPLIES TO BOTH RETAIL THIEVES
AND SECONDARY SELLERS. THIS ITEM
IS A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS RELEASED BY
GOVERNOR NEWSOM. THE BILL ALSO
SPECIFIES THAT THE VALUE OF
THEFTS FROM DIFFERENT VICTIMS
CAN BE AGGREGATED TO REACH THE
THRESHOLD FOR GRAND THEFT, AND
THE RELEVANT INTENT STANDARD CAN
BE MET BY EVIDENCE THAT THE ACTS
INVOLVED THE SAME DEFENDANTS ARE
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR IN NATURE
AND OCCUR WITHIN A 90 DAY
PERIOD. SIGNIFICANTLY, THE BILL
HELPS TO GET AT THE ROOT CAUSE
OF THEFT BY EXPANDING THE USE OF
DIVERSION AND REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS LIKE DRUG COURTS
THROUGH INCREASED SUPERVISION
FOR SHOPLIFTING AND PETTY THEFT,
AND THE OPPORTUNITY FOR EARLY
DISCHARGE FROM PROBATION IF THE
PROGRAM IS COMPLETED. IT ALSO
EXPANDS TOOLS FOR POLICE TO
ARREST SHOPLIFTING BASED ON THE
WITNESSES SWORN STATEMENT OR
VIDEO FOOTAGE. AND THE BILL
EXTENDS THE ABILITY OF POLICE TO
KEEP REPEAT OFFENDERS AND THOSE
COMMITTING ORGANIZED RETAIL
CRIME IN CUSTODY. PROTECT
BUSINESSES AND RETAILERS THAT
REPORT RETAIL CRIME BY ENSURING
THAT THEY WILL NOT HAVE NUISANCE
ACTIONS BROUGHT AGAINST THEM IS
A FINAL COMPONENT OF THE BILL,
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PURSUING REFORMS THAT ARE
EFFECTIVE AT TARGETING RETAIL
CRIME WHILE AVOIDING A WHOLESALE
ROLLBACK OF EXISTING REPORTING
REFORMS THAT HAVE MADE
MEANINGFUL CHANGE AND HAVE
REDUCED THE COST, INCLUDING THE
EMOTIONAL COST, TO OUR
COMMUNITIES OF IMPRISONING
PEOPLE FOR MINOR INFRACTIONS.
WITH THAT. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL INTENDS TO DO. I'M GRATEFUL
FOR THE SPEAKERS LEADERSHIP ON
AB 2943 FOR THE PARTNERSHIP OF
THE PRO TEM AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE CARRYING BILLS THAT ARE
PART OF THE RETAIL CRIME PACKAGE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S STRONG
LEADERSHIP AND TO ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT, INCLUDING RETAILERS,
WORKERS, CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM
ADVOCATES AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. I
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND JUST TO BE SURE, THERE
ARE AMENDS AS WELL THAT YOU'RE
TAKING WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHTY, ARE THERE ANY
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? GOOD
MORNING, MADAM CHAIR CHRIS
MCCAULEY. ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AS IN PRINT, MY CLIENT DOESN'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS,
DANVILLE IS OUT ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NO OPPOSITION
. OH. I'M SORRY. SORRY,
CHAIRWOMAN, NOT TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION, BUT ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION IS OPPOSED TO THE BILL'S
WRITTEN, JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR SPEAKING WITH US AND
TALKING THROUGH SOME OF THE
ISSUES WE HAVE WITH THE BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION DON'T
WANT TO MISS ANYBODY. POLES IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE ROOM ARE
PROBLEMATIC. SO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
ON THIS BILL. SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ANY
COMMENTS, QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS?
SENATOR SATO, WE NEVER CLARIFIED
THE AMENDMENTS. I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THERE WEREN'T ANY MORE
AMENDMENTS ADDED IN ADDITION TO
THE ONES WE TALKED ABOUT,
POTENTIALLY ADDING LAST WEEK
WHEN WE COULD HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THEM, ONE, WAS THE
INTEROPERABILITY CORRECT AND WAS
ONE WAS URGENCY CORRECT? AND
THERE'S NONE OTHER OTHER THAN
THOSE TWO. THAT IS CORRECT. OKAY
AGAIN, THIS THIS ISSUE, 1 TO $10
MILLION A YEAR FAR EXCEEDS THE
$50,000 THRESHOLD FOR PUTTING IT
ON SUSPENSE. IT SHOULD GO ON
SUSPENSE. AND WITHOUT IT, THE
WITH THE INTEROPERABILITY ADDED
INTO IT, IT'S NOT NOT GOING TO
GET A VOTE FROM US. FOR ME,
URGENCY. WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH THAT, THESE BILLS ARE GOOD
BILLS. IF THEY DIDN'T HAVE THAT
INTEROPERABILITY CLAUSE AND
YOU'D HAVE FULL SUPPORT FROM
EVERYBODY, AND THAT WOULD BE A
BIPARTISAN BILL. SO, AGAIN, THE
COST FAR EXCEEDS WHAT WE USUALLY
PUT ON SUSPENSE. AND WE SHOULD
BE PUTTING THESE ON SUSPENSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZABIR, YOU MAY
CONCLUDE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AGAIN, WE
NEED A QUORUM AND SO WE'LL, PASS
ON THAT. I JUST, I JUST. SO WE
HAVE, THREE OTHER BILLS THAT ARE
ON OUR SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS, AND THAT IS AB 1960 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA. AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN WILL BE PRESENTING THAT
AB 1972 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIZ AND THEN AB 3209 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. SO IF WE
COULD URGE THEM TO PRETEND
THEY'RE PART OF THE ON TIME
CAUCUS, THAT WOULD BE REALLY
GOOD, BECAUSE THEN WE COULD GET
ON AND IT LOOKS LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. FABULOUS SO, WE'LL JUST
WAIT A SECOND AND WE'LL TAKE THE
ROLL AND, START DOING BUSINESS.
I JUST.
ALL RIGHT. WE, MADAM ASSISTANT,
PLEASE TAKE THE ROLL. HERE.
CAVERO. HERE. JONES. ASHBY
BECKER. BECKER. HERE. BRADFORD.
CIERTO HERE. SATO. HERE. WAHAB
WAHAB. HERE. NO SO WE. WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. WHILE WE'RE
WAITING FOR THE AUTHORS, LET'S
GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP THE BILLS
THAT WE HAVE ALREADY HEARD,
WE'LL START WITH AB 1779 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN. THE
MOTION IS DO PASS, AS AMENDED.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE
JONES. ASHBY. BECK AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD. CIERTO WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. THAT VOTE THAT BILL
HAS THREE VOTES. WE'LL PUT IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB 1802 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
ACTUALLY, YES I YEAH, THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, ON THIS
BILL AS WELL. OKAY. THERE IS A
SUBSTITUTE MOTION, IT IS CLEAR
THE BILL IS GOING TO HAVE SOME
COSTS AND OUR ANALYSIS AGREES
WITH THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS.
THE RULE FOR, SUSPENSE IS
WHETHER IT'S $50,000 OR MORE.
AND THIS BILL CLEARLY MEETS THAT
CRITERIA TO SEND A SUSPENSE. AND
WE HAVE A HUGE DEFICIT THAT
WE'RE FACING IN OUR BUDGET. AND
SO I MOVE THAT AB 1802 BE SENT
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. AND I WISH
I'D BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT ON THE
PREVIOUS ONE. THANK YOU. THAT'S
ALL GOOD, THERE IS A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION. THE CHAIR RECOMMENDS A
NØ, AND, SENATOR SATO AND I,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO.
NO. CABALLERO. NO JONES. ASHBY.
BECKER AYE. BECKER. OH, NO.
BECKER. NO THAT WAS GOOD.
BRADFORD. CIERTO I CIERTO I
WAHAB. WAHAB. NO THE MOTION
FAILS. THANKFULLY AND SO THE
MOTION TO, DO PASSES AMENDED, IS
NEXT. AND THAT'S AN AYE VOTE. MY
RECOMMENDATION IS AYE CABALLERO
A CABALLERO. AYE. JONES ASHBY.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
CIERTO. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE THAT
BILL HAS THREE VOTE. WE'RE GOING
TO PLACE IT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE UP AB 2943 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF BIR. AND THE
MOTION IS Dð PASSES AMEND. I
HAVE A SUBSTITUTE MOTION. VERY
GOOD, I MOVE THAT AB, 2943 BE
SENT TO THE SUSPENSE FILE. IT IS
A SUBSTITUTE MOTION, THE CHAIR
RECOMMENDS A NO VOTE, AND
SENATOR CIERTO AND I VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
NO. CABALLERO. NO JONES. ASHBY
BECKER. NO. BECKER. NO.
BRADFORD. CIERTO NO. CIERTO. I
WAHAB. WAHAB. NO THAT BILL
FAILS. SO MOVE ON TO THE MOTION
IN CHIEF WHICH IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES ASHBY. BECKER. BECKER. AYE
BRADFORD. CIERTO WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE THAT BILL HAS THREE VOTES.
WE'LL PUT IT ON. CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND I SEE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIZ IS HERE.
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO AB 1972 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIZ. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY. THAT WAS A BIG SIGH.
WE'RE NOT THAT MEAN. WELL, I
JUST CAME OUT OF ONE COMMITTEE.
I, I HAD SOME WITNESSES WHO
WERE, BLIND. I HAD TO HELP THEM
DOWN TO THE FIRST FLOOR. SO I'M
JUST RUNNING BACK UP HERE TO BE
HERE FOR YOU GUYS. OUT OF
BREATH? YES A LITTLE BIT. ALL
RIGHT. WELL, THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. MR. VICE CHAIR MEMBERS,
TODAY I AM PROUD TO PRESENT 1972
AB 1972, WHICH WILL ENHANCE OUR
STATE'S ABILITY TO
COMPREHENSIVELY RESPOND TO CARGO
THEFT. AB 1972 EXPANDS ON THE
SUCCESSFUL CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROLS REGIONAL PROPERTY CRIME
TASK FORCE TO SUPPORT IDENTIFIED
COUNTIES WITH INCREASED LEVELS
OF CARGO THEFT. THE BILL WILL
ALSO REQUIRE THE CHP TO PROVIDE
RAILROAD POLICE WITH LOGISTICAL
SUPPORT AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES LIKE
PERSONNEL AND EQUIPMENT, AND THE
FURTHERANCE OF COMBATING CARGO
THEFT. AS PART OF THE LARGER
ASSEMBLY RETAIL THEFT PACKAGE
INTRODUCED ALONGSIDE SOME OF MY
DEMOCRATIC COLLEAGUES, THIS BILL
WILL FURTHER OUR SHARED GOALS OF
STRENGTHENING OUR LAWS AND
PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE
TO OUR BUSINESSES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
STRUGGLED TO RESPOND TO THE
GROWING NUMBER OF RETAIL THEFT
CRIMES THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AB
1972 IS ONLY ONE ELEMENT OF THE
LARGER SOLUTION THAT CALIFORNIA
MUST EMPLOY IN ORDER TO SOLVE
THIS MULTI PROLONGED ISSUE. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND REQUEST FOR AN AYE VOTE. SO,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THERE IS AN
AMENDMENT THAT I UNDERSTAND
YOU'RE GOING TO BE TAKING. YES,
I WILL BE TAKING. I'M SORRY I
MISSED THAT PART TWO I WILL BE
YES. TAKING AMENDMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS, DAN
FELIZARDO, ON BEHALF OF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THÀNH SIMILAR
STATEMENT BEFORE MADAM CHAIR,
ACLU DOES HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL AND WE ARE REMAINING IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOESN'T HAVE A FILE ON
THIS BILL, SO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
SENATOR SATO, I HAVE A QUESTION.
WHAT IS THE AMENDMENT THAT IS
THERE GOING TO BE TAKING ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL? SO THE URGENCY,
INOPERABILITY. AND URGENCY, YES.
THE ACTUALLY HOLD ON. I GOT THE
ACTUAL I DON'T MISQUOTE ANYTHING
URGENCY. I THINK JUST JUST OKAY.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S JUST THE URGENCY
TO MAKE SURE THEY KNOW THAT THE
IN OUR INOPERABILITY AMENDMENT
IS NOT GOING TO END INTO THE
BILL. OKAY. VERY GOOD. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WITH
THAT CLARIFICATION. WATCH THIS.
WATCH THIS OKAY. SO NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS, ASSEMBLY MEMBER, IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. I'M
JUST I'M VERY PROUD TO BE PART
OF THIS PACKAGE TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND
I REQUEST YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, THERE IS A MOTION ON
THIS DO PASS, AS AMENDED. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE JONES. ASHBY.
BECKER AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. CIERTO. CIERTO AYE.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THAT HAS FOUR, FOUR VOTES
AND WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
THIS. HE'S FOCUSED. HE'S FOCUSED
. COME ON, SENATOR OKAY. SO NOW.
SO WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR ONE
MORE PRESENTATION ON TWO BILLS,
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT ARE HERE
FOR AB 1794, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTHY, HE,
MCCARTHY, HE HAS PULLED HIS
BILL. SO WE WILL NOT BE HEARING
IT TODAY. OKAY. SO WE'LL MOVE ON
TO OUR, THE MEASURES THAT ARE
NOT THE SPECIAL ORDER OF THE
DAY, AND WE'LL START WITH. AB
990CO MR. BURNS HERE. OH VERY
GOOD. DID THEY GIVE THE BILL?
SCRATCH THAT. WE DO HAVE AN
AUTHOR. WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. THANK YOU. CHAIR
CABRERA, WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE
UP THIS BILL OR YOUR YOUR OWN
FIRST? SURE. I'LL DO FOR THE
BILL. HOW ABOUT WE TAKE UP AB
1960 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA,
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
PRESENTING. THANK YOU FOR DOING
THAT. MY PLEASURE. AND FOR THE
RECORD, I GUESS IT'S THE STORY
OF BILL FOR ANOTHER TWO SECONDS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB 1960, ON BEHALF OF
THE BILL'S NEW AUTHOR, SPEAKER
ROBERT RIVAS, AB 1960 RESTORES
AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO COMBAT RETAIL
THEFT AND KEEP OUR COMMUNITIES
SAFE. SPECIFICALLY IT REINSTATES
A TIERED SENTENCING ENHANCEMENT
IF THE VALUE OF PROPERTY STOLEN
OR DAMAGED DURING A FELONY IS
EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH. THIS BILL
BOLSTERS TOOLS FOR POLICE AND
PROSECUTORS TO TAKE DOWN THOSE
WHO COMMIT AND PROFIT FROM SMASH
AND GRABS, AND AB 1960 IS PART
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF BILLS
TO ADDRESS RETAIL CRIME AND
THEFT IN A MEANINGFUL AND
BALANCED WAY. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THERE ARE AMENDS. ON THIS
BILL, AND I ASSUME YOU'RE TAKING
THOSE AMENDS. YEAH, I AM
ABSOLUTELY TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS. VERY GOOD. SO NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 1960.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, COREY SUSILO, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION, WITHOUT
THE BENEFIT OF SEEING ADDITIONAL
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS, OUR
POSITION IS THE SAME AS ON MR.
IRWIN'S BILL. WE ARE SUPPORT. IF
THE BILL IS NOT AMENDED AND WILL
BE REMOVING SUPPORT IF IT
CONTAINS THE INOPERABILITY
CLAUSE. THANK YOU. UNDERSTOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. Dð
COONEY, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION, WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS WRITTEN.
WE FEEL EXISTING LAW IS MORE
THAN SUFFICIENT TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE. BUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION IN. ALL RIGHT. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL. SO
WE'LL MOVE ON TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS COMMENTS, QUESTIONS.
SEN. SATO, WHAT A SURPRISE. IT
IS A SURPRISE. IT'S A PLEASURE A
PLEASURE AND AN HONOR, SIR.
AGAIN, MISS SORIA, I'M SORRY,
ASSEMBLY THE SPEAKERS. BILL, HAS
A COST OF 150,000 TO $1 MILLION
PER YEAR, WHICH FAR EXCEEDS OUR
$50,000 RULE TO GO TO SUSPENSE.
AND SO THIS MEETS THAT. AND, SO,
SO WITH THE INTEROPERABILITY
CLAUSE AGAIN, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO, SUPPORT EVEN THOUGH WE
SUPPORT, TRYING TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT OUR CRIME USING THESE
BILLS, AS NOTED IN THE LAST VOTE
THAT DIDN'T HAVE THE
INTEROPERABILITY CLAUSE, AND WE
VOTED IN FAVOR OF THAT BILL. SO,
WITH THAT SAID, APPRECIATE YOU
PRESENTING THE BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE SPEAKER. THANK YOU, SIR.
VERY GOOD. SEEING NO OTHER
COMMENTS THERE, THERE IS A
MOTION, SUBSTITUTE MOTION. ALL
RIGHT. WE'LL TAKE UP THAT
SUBSTITUTE MOTION AFTER WE'VE
HEARD THE CLOSING. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE OUT, NOW'S YOUR
TIME, ON BEHALF OF SPEAKER
RIVAS, I AM, QUITE, I AM QUITE
CERTAIN THAT HE WOULD BE OPPOSED
TO ANY SUBSTITUTE AMENDMENTS OR
MOTIONS, AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THERE IS A
SUBSTITUTE MOTION, SEN CIERTO. I
MOVE THAT AB 1960 BE SENT TO
DISPENSE FILE. THERE IS A
SUBSTITUTE MOTION. THE CHAIR
WILL VOTE NO AND ASK FOR A NO
VOTE. THE, SENATOR SATO IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CABALLERO. NO
CAFIERO. NO. JONES. JONES AYE.
ASHBY. BECKER. NO BECKER. NO.
BRADFORD. CIERTO AYE. SATO. AYE.
WAHAB. WAHAB NO. THE MOTION
FAILS. THE SUBSTITUTE. THE
AMENDMENT IN CHIEF IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE JONES.
ASHBY BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. CIERTO WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE BILL HAS THREE VOTE VOTES.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT IT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AND THAT
LEAVES YOUR BILL WHICH IS A FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB 3209. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR. AND SENATORS
AB 3209 WOULD PROVIDE A NEW
ENFORCEMENT TOOL THAT WILL KEEP
STORES AND WORKERS SAFE FROM THE
RISE OF RETAIL CRIME.
SPECIFICALLY, IT WOULD AUTHORIZE
A COURT TO IMPOSE A RETAIL CRIME
RESTRAINING ORDER FOR UP TO TWO
YEARS FOR THEFT, VANDALISM OR
BATTERY ON AN EMPLOYEE WITHIN
THE STORE. THE BILL STRIKES A
BALANCE BETWEEN PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT TOOL TO
KEEP STORES, CUSTOMERS AND
WORKERS SAFE WHILE NOT
PERPETUATING THE UNDERLYING
CAUSES OF RETAIL THEFT, SUCH AS
POVERTY. AB 3209 IS ALSO PART OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE OF BILLS TO ADDRESS
RETAIL CRIME AND THEFT. IN A
THOUGHTFUL AND BALANCED WAY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. VERY GOOD. AGAIN, YOU'RE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT AND I AM
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS. ALL
RIGHT. VERY GOOD, WE'LL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL? IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. Dð COONEY, ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION, WE ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS BILL AS
WELL, WE FEEL THAT IT ELEVATES A
LOT OF WELL-RESOURCED RETAIL
CHAINS ABOVE OTHER VICTIMS OF
VIOLENT CRIME WHO DESPERATELY
NEED RESOURCES AND SHOULD BE
GREATLY CONSIDERED THAN SOME OF
THESE BIG BOX RETAILERS. BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS. SO,
THIS BRINGS IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SENATOR CIERTO SAME
ISSUES AS PREVIOUS THIS FAR
EXCEEDS THE $50,000, FOR,
ELIGIBILITY TO GO TO SUSPENSE
AND, AND IT ALSO HAS THE
INTEROPERABILITY, AMENDMENT IN
IT. AND SO THEREFORE WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD. SEEING NO OTHER,
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN, YOU MAY CONCLUDE,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
VERY GOOD, MOVE THE BILL. THERE
IS A MOTION. I HAVE A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION. THERE IS A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION. SENATOR SATO, ON YOUR
SUBSTITUTE MOTION, I MOVE THAT
AB 3209 BE SENT TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE APPROPRIATELY. THE CHAIR
RECOMMENDS A NÓ RECOMMENDATION,
AND SENATOR SATO AND I. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO NO.
CABALLERO. NO. JONES. JONES. AYE
ASHBY. BECKER. NO. BECKER. NO
BRADFORD. SATO. AYE SATO. AYE.
WAHAB. NO. WAHAB NO. VERY GOOD.
THE MOTION FAILS DESPITE THE
FACT THAT SENATOR JONES IS OVER
THERE TRYING TO LOBBY. AND WE
HAVE THE MOTION IN CHIEF, WHICH
IS DO PASS AS AMENDED. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE JONES. I'M SORRY
I MISSED IT. THIS IS FOR. THIS
IS THE MOTION IN CHIEF. OH.
LOVING HIM. NO ASHBY. BECKER.
AYE BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. SATO
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE YOUR BILL HAS
THREE VOTES. WE'LL PUT IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO THANK
YOU. VERY GOOD. SO THAT
CONCLUDES OUR SPECIAL ORDER OF
BUSINESS. AGAIN AB 1794 WAS
PULLED OUT. WE HAVE TWO MORE
VOTES, MY STAFF, AND WE WILL
MOVE ON TO, OUR SUSPENSE FILE AB
NINE 990 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON, ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO
WE'LL GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES PRESENT WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 990?
IF SO, PLEASE COME FORWARD. HOW
ABOUT ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? ARE THERE
ANY COMMITTEE QUESTIONS ON THIS
BILL? IF NOT, I'LL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. THIS. OH, ACTUALLY, THIS
BILL IS A SUSPENSE. FILE
CANDIDATES. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 990 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. GOT A GOT TO GET IN
THE GROOVE HERE. SO AB AB 1516
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB 1516? ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NONE. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE? IF
NOT, THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION, SB 1516 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB 1725
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY.
SENATOR. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO WE
WILL GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF 1725? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION 1725. THIS BILL IS A
IS A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 1725 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO AB 2076 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. SENATOR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES WHO WOULD LIKE TO,
PRESENT OR TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
2076? WELCOME GOOD MORNING,
MARIO GUERRERO, ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA, THIS
BILL WOULD ALLOW US TO BUILD A
MORE AFFORDABLE ON STUDENT
HOUSING ON CAMPUS. WE APPRECIATE
AN AYE VOTE IN CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE A FINANCE
ON THIS ONE. SO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
PRESENT, YOU'RE ALWAYS WELCOME
AT THE TABLE, BUT THAT WORKS
FINE TOO. I APPRECIATE IT, SINCE
WE ONLY HAVE QUÊ FILES TODAY,
I'LL MAKE IT EASY AND GO BACK
AND FORTH, THANK THANK YOU.
CHAIR MICHELLE PERRAULT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOTE
AN OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL. THE
BILL WOULD TRANSFER $200 MILLION
FROM THE POOLED MONEY INVESTMENT
ACCOUNT. THE PMEA ACCOUNT INTO
THE STUDENT HOUSING REVOLVING
LOAN FUND, WE WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT THE USE OF THE PMEA WITHOUT
SPECIFIED REPAYMENT FUNDS
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURE TO THE GENERAL FUND,
WHICH HAS NOT BEEN INCLUDED IN
THE 2024 BUDGET OR IN ANY OF OUR
MULTIYEAR PROJECTIONS, THE USE
OF THIS FUND IN THIS MANNER ALSO
IS GOING TO PRESENT SOME OUTYEAR
RISKS RELATED TO THE STATE'S
FISCAL FLEXIBILITY AND COULD
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COSTS BY
NECESSITATING SOME EXTERNAL CASH
FLOW BORROWING FROM GENERAL FUND
. THAT WOULD BE NOTED. ALSO,
WE'RE UNCERTAIN ABOUT HOW THE
BILL COULD IMPACT OUR RATING
AGENCY ASSESSMENTS OF OUR FISCAL
MANAGEMENT AND CREDIT
CREDITWORTHINESS, WHICH
OBVIOUSLY IS SOMETHING WE ARE
ALWAYS MINDFUL OF. AND THEN
LASTLY, WE WOULD JUST NOTE THAT
THIS THIS PROPOSAL REALLY IS
INCONSISTENT WITH THE INTENDED
USE OF PMEA. IT'S NEVER BEEN
USED FOR THIS TYPE OF PURPOSE,
AND IT'S REALLY KIND OF UNCLEAR
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT IT'S
APPROPRIATE UNDER OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL DEBT LIMIT. WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION DID HAVE PROPOSED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AS PART OF
THE 2024 BUDGET PACKAGE, WHICH
WILL CREATE A LEASE REVENUE BOND
FINANCING PROGRAM, WHICH COULD
PROVIDE SOME OF THE AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITHOUT
HAVING TO USE PMEA. SO AT THIS
TIME, WE'RE OPPOSED. VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY. ANY QUESTIONS OR
CONCERNS BY THE COMMITTEE?
SEEING NONE, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATES. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE, A B 2076 TO SUSPENSE,
IF YOU'D LIKE, I'LL TAKE UP THE
OTHER BILL. FOR WHICH WHICH
YOU'RE HERE. WHY DON'T WE MOVE
ON TO A B 2120 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHEN, LET ME ASK FIRST.
LET ME SAY THAT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION, SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO DIRECTLY TO
THE WITNESS TESTIMONY. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB 2120?
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO 2120. SEEING
NONE. DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, CHAIR.
APPRECIATE THAT AGAIN.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE DO
CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE ON THIS
BILL. WE DO BELIEVE THE BUREAU
OF SECURITY INVESTIGATION,
INVESTIGATIVE SERVICES, DOES
ANTICIPATE AN ABSORBABLE COSTS
OF $138,000 FROM THE PRIVATE
SECURITY SERVICES FUND IN 25, 26
AND 129,000 IN 2627, AND ONGOING
FOR A ONE STAFF SERVICE ANALYST
POSITION TO REVIEW AND
INVESTIGATE THE COMPLAINTS. THE
ESTIMATED COST TO IMPLEMENT THE
BILL DOES INCLUDE SOME FUNDS OF
$1,000 AND 2526 TO UPDATE THE
CODES, BUT WHAT WE WOULD NOTE IS
THE PRIVATE SECURITY SERVICES
FUND IS STRUCTURALLY IMBALANCED
AT THIS TIME, AND ADDITIONAL
COSTS WOULD CONTRIBUTE TO A NEED
FOR A FEE INCREASE. SO THEREFORE
WE ARE OPPOSED. VERY GOOD. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, A B 2120 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. OKAY, WE'LL GO
BACK TO THE TO THE TOP OF THE
LIST OR WHERE WE WERE LEFT OFF A
B 1792 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO DIRECTLY TO THOSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE COME FORWARD. IS THERE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO ONE,
THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE, SO WITHOUT OBJECTION,
A B 1792 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE A
B 1937 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION A B 1938. SORRY IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF A B
1938? IS THERE ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
A B 1938? SEEING NO, SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE. FINALIST. I GUESS I
NEED MORE COFFEE. THIS BILL IS
AGAIN SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE.
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION, A B 1938
WILL MOVE TO SUSPEND. OKAY
ALRIGHTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN,
I SEE THAT YOU ARE HERE. SO
WE'RE GOING TO JUMP AHEAD IN THE
AGENDA AND, MOVE ON TO A B 23,
EXCUSE ME, 2123 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PEPIN. WELCOME THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. GOOD MORNING.
MEMBERS NICE TO BE WITH ALL OF
YOU, SO I'M HERE TO PRESENT A B
2123, WHICH IS REALLY A VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL. AND WHAT
IT BASICALLY SAYS IS THAT AN
EMPLOYER MAY NOT REQUIRE YOU TO
TAKE TWO WEEKS OF VACATION
BEFORE YOU CAN START COLLECTING
ON YOUR PAID FAMILY LEAVE, SO MY
BILL REMOVES THE PROVISION THAT
WOULD THAT ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO
DO THIS. SINCE EMPLOYEES PAY
INTO THIS PROGRAM, THEY SHOULD
BE ABLE TO ACCESS THESE BENEFITS
WITHOUT STRINGS ATTACHED,
BECAUSE THE P PAID FAMILY LEAVE
PROGRAM IS FINANCED SOLELY BY
THE WORKERS THEMSELVES. THIS
BILL HAS A MODEST FISCAL IMPACT,
THAT INCLUDES A ONE TIME COST OF
$67,000 TO EDD AND HERE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I HAVE A
WITNESS THAT IS MISS JULIA
PARRISH, AND SHE COMES TO US
FROM LEGAL AID AT WORK. THANK
YOU. MY NAME IS JULIA PARRISH.
I'M A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
LEGAL AID AT WORK, WHICH IS A
STATEWIDE NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES FREE LEGAL SERVICES FOR
LOW WAGE WORKERS. AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE WE HEAR ABOUT A LOT ON OUR
HELPLINE. WE HEAR FROM THOUSANDS
OF FAMILIES A YEAR, ONE WORKERS
GET VERY CONFUSED ABOUT THE WAY
THAT THEY CAN ACCESS PAID FAMILY
LEAVE BENEFITS. IT CAN LEAD TO
THEM MAKING MISTAKES IN IN
APPLYING. ELIMINATING THIS
REQUIREMENT EASES THAT
APPLICATION PROCESS FOR ALL
USERS AND ALSO INCREASES ACCESS
TO PAID FAMILY LEAVE BENEFITS,
WHICH HAVE NUMEROUS IMPORTANT
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OUTCOMES
FOR FAMILIES, PARTICULARLY FOR
FAMILIES WITH LOW INCOMES WHO
CAN'T ACCESS THE THAT TIME OFF
WITHOUT THESE BENEFITS AND AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER PAPAN SAID, IT'S
ENTIRELY WORKER FUNDED IT IS NOT
GENERAL FUND MONEY, AND,
REMOVING THIS IMPACT WOULD ALLOW
FOLKS TO USE THE BENEFITS THAT
THEY HAVE BEEN PAYING IN FOR,
AND THEN ALSO SAVE ANY VACATION
TIME THEY HAVE FOR OTHER NEEDS
THAT COME UP, PARTICULARLY WHEN
WELCOMING A NEW CHILD. YOU NEED
THOSE TIME WHEN YOUR CHILD GETS
SICK OR YOU HAVE TO GO TO A
FIELD TRIP OR THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO WE THINK THAT THIS IS A
MODEST CHANGE THAT WILL HAVE A
PROFOUND IMPACT FOR LOTS OF
WORKING FAMILIES ACROSS THE
STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT? HELLO. JUSTIN BOWERS,
ON BEHALF OF CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS STRONGLY SUPPORTS. AND IN
ADDITION, THE NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND NCCA
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW
ABOUT ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING
NONE, WE'LL BRING, THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. THERE IS
A MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. DO
PASS. ANY QUESTIONS, COMMENTS OR
CONCERNS? SEEING NONE. YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR. JUST REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THE MOTION
IS DUE. PASS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE. CAVERO
AYE. JONES. AYE. JONES. AYE
ASHBY. BECKER BRADFORD. CIERTO
CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE.
BILL HAS FOUR VOTES. WE'LL PUT
IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO WHERE WE LEFT OFF AND
THAT IS AB 1943 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
1943? WELCOME. HELLO. JUSTIN
BOWERS ON BEHALF OF CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS. STRONGLY SUPPORTS AND
IN ADDITION, THE NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND NCCA
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, CLIFTON WILSON.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. KEISHA, WHAT'S
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND SUPPORT?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
OPPOSITION, THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AB 1943 WILL MOVE TO
SUSPENSE. MOVE ON TO AB 2250 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. AGAIN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO WITNESS TESTIMONY. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HI.
TEISHA WATTS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS,
PROUD SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. HELLO,
JUSTIN BOWERS, ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS, STRONGLY
SUPPORTS AND IN ADDITION, NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE FACTS
ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND
NCCA ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2250 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND. I'M GOING TO
MOVE ON TO AB 2024 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PACHECO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PACHECO HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION.
IS THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2024? ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NEITHER THIS BILL IS A SUSPENSE
FILE CANDIDATE. SO WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE AB 2024 TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE. MOVING ON TO AB 2131 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALENCIA, WHO
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? ANYONE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NEITHER THIS
AGAIN IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO AB 2131 WILL MOVE
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO AB
2137 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE HERE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO 2137?
AGAIN, SEEING NEITHER THE IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2137 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2449 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER TO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? AGAIN, THIS IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO AB
2449 WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
2631 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL.
2621. I'M CHECKING TO SEE IF
ANYBODY'S AWAKE, AGAIN, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GABRIEL HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? WELCOME THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. DANNY OFFER WITH
EVERYTOWN FOR GUN SAFETY, WHERE
THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. VERY
GOOD. ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT OF
2621? HOW ABOUT ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2621 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE AB 2707 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE FONG.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. IS THERE ANYONE
HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT? ANYONE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION? THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2707 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPEND AB 2725 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION. SO WE'RE GOING TO
GO DIRECTLY TO WITNESS
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE HERE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF 2725? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? AGAIN, THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE. SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 2725 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB 3134 3143
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOWENTHAL HAS
WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS THERE
ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HOW ABOUT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION? AGAIN, AB
3143 IS A SUSPENSE FILE
CANDIDATE. SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
IT WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AB
3223 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON AS WELL
HAS WAIVED PRESENTATION. IS
THERE ANYONE HERE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HI JUSTIN
BOWERS ON BEHALF OF CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE, ECO
SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS AND NCCA
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT? ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION? AGAIN, THIS BILL IS
A SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 3230 3223
WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE. AND
FINALLY AB 3245 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JO PATTERSON. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PATTERSON HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION SO WE'LL GO
DIRECTLY TO WITNESS TESTIMONY.
IS THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT? HELLO,
JUSTIN BOWERS, ON BEHALF OF
CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS, ORG
STRONGLY SUPPORTS. ADDITIONALLY,
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
ECO SUSTAINABILITY PIECE AND THE
NCCA ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORTS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT? IS THERE
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NO
OPPOSITION. THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE FILE CANDIDATE, SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. AB 3245 WILL
MOVE TO SUSPENSE. ARE ONE FILE
LEFT.
JUST PROMOTED YOU TO VICE CHAIR.
YOU'RE THE VICE CHAIR. YOU'D BE
KIND.
I TOOK THE GAVEL BACK FROM Ó. I
WAS WHOOPS, MY BAD. TO KEEP IT
MORE LIKE A HOT POTATO. ALL
RIGHT, WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
ITEM EIGHT, SENATE BILL 1481 BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. CLAIMS
AGAINST THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR SHAPIRO,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MR. VICE
CHAIR, SB 1481 IS THE SECOND
CLAIMS BILL CARRIED BY THE
CHAIRS OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE EACH YEAR TO PROVIDE
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY FOR
LEGAL JUDGMENTS AND SETTLEMENTS
APPROVED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THIS
URGENCY BILL APPROPRIATES 19.3
MILLION FROM THE GENERAL FUND TO
DOJ FOR THE PAYMENT OF THE
FOLLOWING CLAIMS AGAINST THE
STATE. AUBURN VERSUS BONTA.
DAVIS VERSUS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SALAS ORTEZ VERSUS
THE CALIFORNIA VICTIMS
COMPENSATION BOARD, A
COORDINATED PROCEEDING OF FIVE
CASES AGAINST THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. AND
WELCH VERSUS BONTA. THESE
JUDGMENTS AND SETTLEMENTS ARE
BINDING STATE OBLIGATIONS. ANY
FUNDS APPROPRIATED IN EXCESS OF
THE AMOUNTS REQUIRED FOR THE
CLAIMS WILL REVERT TO THE
GENERAL FUND. WITH ME TODAY ARE
JUSTIN ROSA AND OTHER
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, WHO CAN
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE INDIVIDUAL CLAIMS. I
ALSO HAVE AUTHOR'S AMENDMENTS
TO, TO OFFER IN ORDER TO ADDRESS
SEVERAL TECHNICAL ISSUES. AS
SPECIFIED IN THE STAFF ANALYSIS,
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. SENATOR,
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, GOOD
MORNING, MR. VICE CHAIR. AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DISCUSS SB 1481
WITH YOU ON BEHALF OF THE
SPONSOR, ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB
BONTA. WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE
DETAILED BILL ANALYSIS AND TO
CHAIR CABALLERO FOR AUTHORING SB
1481, SIMILAR TO THE FIRST
CLAIMS BILL THAT WAS BROUGHT
BEFORE YOU LAST WEEK, SB 1481 IS
A BILL THAT WOULD APPROPRIATE
19,289,000 FROM THE GENERAL FUND
TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR THE
PAYMENT OF CLAIMS, SETTLEMENTS
OR JUDGMENTS AGAINST THE STATE
ARISING FROM THE FIVE SPECIFIED
ACTIONS IN WHICH THE STATE WAS
REPRESENTED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL. AS DESCRIBED BY CHAIR
CABALLERO, JOINING ME TODAY ARE
SUPERVISING DEPUTY ATTORNEYS
GENERAL BRUCE MCGUIGAN AND ANYA
BENZACAR, AND DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL ALISON GOLDSMITH. IN
CASE YOU HAVE ANY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS ON BEHALF OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
CLIFTON WILSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH SAN JOAQUIN IRRIGATION
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT? ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? NONE. ONE MORE TIME.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE, DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES
NOT HAVE A FILE ON THIS BILL. SO
WE'LL MOVE TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
HAVE A COMMENT. SENATOR SATO.
ALL RIGHT, WELL, THERE ARE
CLAIMS THAT ARE CERTAINLY
SUPPORTABLE, THERE ARE ALSO
CLAIMS THAT ARE HIGHLY
QUESTIONABLE BECAUSE THESE ARE
THESE ARE OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS
GOING OUT. AND, AND ONE OF THESE
CASES, IT APPEARS THAT CRIME
DOES PAY, IT IS CLEAR THAT THIS
PERSON ACTUALLY DID DO THE
CRIME, AND NOW HE'S BEING
COMPENSATED FOR THAT, AND HIS
ATTORNEYS ARE BEING COMPENSATED.
THE PERSON WAS ALREADY
COMPENSATED 800,000. NOW HIS
ATTORNEYS NEED 1.625. FOR THEIR
WORK ON, FINDING WHATEVER
TECHNICALITY IT WAS THAT THEY
WERE ABLE TO GET HIM,
UNCONVICTED ON, BUT, THEY ARE,
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE,
SAYS THAT HE IS, IN FACT, GUILTY
OF THIS CRIME. THESE SHOULD BE
SEPARATED OUT, SO THAT THE ONES
THAT ARE ARE VERY SUPPORTABLE.
YOU KNOW, WE CAN GET THOSE
THROUGH, BUT FOR US TO CONTINUE
TO, TO COMPENSATE PEOPLE FOR
CRIMES THAT THEY ACTUALLY DID IS
ABSURD. AND SO I'M GOING TO BE
LAYING OFF THIS, BECAUSE I WANT
THESE SEPARATED OUT SO THAT WE
CAN ACTUALLY VOTE NO ON THE ONES
THAT ARE RIDICULOUS. AND, AND,
YOU KNOW, PUT THE OTHER ONES
FORWARD, THAT CLEARLY, ARE OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO PAY OUT. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS? I'LL MOVE THE
BILL. THERE IS A MOTION ON THE
BILL. SENATOR, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE OR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE? THANK YOU. SENATOR,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
CABALLERO I CABALLERO I JONES.
NOT VOTING. ASHBY. BECKER
BRADFORD. CIERTO WAHAB. WAHAB I.
THE CURRENT VOTE IS 2 TO 0.
WE'LL PUT THE BILL ON CALL FOR
MEMBERS TO COME DOWN AND ADD ON.
AND I'LL TURN THE GAVEL BACK TO
THE PROPER HOLDER OF THE GAVEL.
RIGHT NOW. AND PRACTICE OFFICE
AT FIVE MINUTES OUT. OKAY OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT, THAT,
CONCLUDES THE BILLS WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP TODAY. WE NEED TO
HAVE THE ABSENT MEMBERS, COME TO
THE COMMITTEE IN ORDER TO VOTE.
SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A, A
SHORT RECESS SO THAT WE CAN GET
OUR ABSENT MEMBERS.
SO WE'RE BACK, SENATOR,
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IS BACK
IN ORDER IN, ORDER. AND WE'RE
GOING TO LIFT THE CALL ON AB
1972, WHICH IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ALANIZ, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE SENATE FLOOR.
JONES I, JONES I ASHBY BRADFORD.
THAT IS 5 TO 0. AND WE'RE GOING
TO PUT IT ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. SO WE'RE WAITING FOR
THE LAST TWO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, AND THEN WE'LL LIFT
THE CALL ON ALL OF THE BILLS. SO
WE ARE BACK IN RECESS AGAIN.
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IS BACK IN IN SESSION.
SO WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP THE
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS, BILLS
FIRST, AND WE'LL RUN RIGHT
THROUGH THEM. AND THEN WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF BILLS. THAT WERE HEARD
IN FILE ORDER. SO LET ME JUST
SAY THAT, AB 1794 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY WAS PULLED. AND
SO WE DID NOT TAKE THAT UP
TODAY. WE'LL START WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WINS AB 1779. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED AS AMENDED. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. JONES ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD BRADFORD.
AYE. CIERTO FINAL VOTE IS FIVE
ZERO. THAT BILL IS OUT, THE VOTE
IS 5 TO 0. MOVING ON TO AB 1802
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JONES ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO 5
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO AB NINE TÍNH 60.
AND THAT BILL IS BY SPEAKER
RIVAS. AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
JONES ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO
THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO AB 1972 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIS. THE MOTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE THAT BILL IS OUT 7
TO 0. AB 2943 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ZEBRA THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. JONES ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BRADFORD BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO 5
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO AB 30 209 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN. THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL JONES ASHBY
. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO ZERO. THAT
BILL IS OUT 5 TO 0. NEXT IS SB
1481 BY MYSELF SENATOR
CABALLERO. THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AS AMENDED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
JONES. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO 5 TO
0. 5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. I
WAS GOING TO TAKE NOTES. AND
FINALLY AB 2130 23 2123 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPAN. THE
MOTION IS DUE PASS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ASHBY. Ã. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD AYE. 7 TO 0.
7 TO 0. THAT THAT BILL IS OUT.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA FOR
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU TO EVERYONE
WHO TESTIFIED TODAY AND MADE OUR
JOB A LOT EASIER. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. WE ARE ADJOURNED.